You know stock music always makes me feel
so productive.
Hi there harmonically inclined homies, Trace
here for DNews.
We all know music has the power to alter behaviours,
like when Queen Bey makes you dance or Adele
helps you work through a difficult breakup.
But music also helps us get through more mundane
times, like the workday.
When I’m writing, I like to put on my headphones
and pump up the jams… like Girl Talk or
the National Treasure soundtrack.
No judgement.
And that may not be such a bad thing.
A recent study in the Journal of Organizational
Behavior took a close look at how music affects
cooperation.
Researchers put 78 college students into two
groups: one exposed to happy music, and the
other exposed to unhappy music.4
Now, before we go any further, we know “happy”
is a pretty broad term, but according to these
researchers they decided to add “Yellow
Submarine” by the Beatles; “Walking on
Sunshine” by Katrina and the Waves; and
-- of course -- the theme song from “Happy
Days” to this happy music playlist.4 And
for unhappy music, they played songs from
less familiar heavy metal bands.
Tunes like “Smokahontas” by Attack Attack!
and “You Ain't No Family” by Iwrestledabearonce.4
Cool band name, by the way.
Alright, back to the study.
Individuals had to decide how much money they
wanted to put into a group pool and how much
they wanted to keep for themselves.
To incentivize cooperation, money put into
the pool would be multiplied one and a half
times before being split evenly.
The results showed that contributions into
the pool were about one-third higher than
with happy music than with unhappy.
And listening to music you like is not just
good for group work.
A music therapy expert at the University of
Miami conducted a study with 56 computer developers
who were asked to keep a detailed music log.
In the log, participants recorded how they
felt before and after listening to music,
how long they listened, and their music selections.
The log was then compared to their overall
quality of work.
The results showed that developers came up
with better ideas plus worked better and faster
with music on.
Without music, they had poorer work quality
overall.
So music may make you more cooperative and
increase your productivity, but there is also
evidence that it can sometimes have a negative
effect, depending on the task at hand.
One study at Florida Atlantic University observed
45 students to see how fast they wrote essays
with or without music.
The results showed that those who listened
to music while writing wrote slower by an
average of 60 words per hour, concluding that
music may actually be distracting when doing
something as cognitive as essay writing.
So when it comes to music in the workplace,
remember that there are as many variables
as there are different musical genres.
Not only should you consider happy versus
unhappy music -- whatever that may be for
you -- but also consider what it is you actually
do at work.
If you’re going through a vacation's worth
of junk email, go ahead and turn on those
beats!
But if you’re trying to meet a tight deadline
on a quarterly report, silence just may be
your best bet.
Understanding how music can affect you is
not just good for getting work done, it's
a profitable area of study.
Casinos also use music and different musical
cues to keep you gambling and happy.
I learned that in Casino Secrets on DiscoveryGO.
DiscoveryGo lets you watch your favorite Discovery
shows on your phone or tablet.
Download it for free at your app store!
So just because “Yellow Submarine” was
classified as “happy” music by some researchers
doesn’t necessary mean it’s good music...or
does it?
- Is There A Formula Behind Good Music?
Host Jules talks more about it in this video.
What do you listen to when you want to get
ish done?
Seriously, I am standing by this National
Treasure Soundtrack.
It's amazing for my brain…
I can't do a Nick Cage impression, but if
i could I would.